this is Drake's dad pictured on the
cover of his 2017 album more life this
is french comedian jacques rougeau in
1969 this is country star larry gatlin
in 1979 and sole artist out green in
1972 this is the british synth pop pan
heaven 17 in 1981 these artists works
been decades genres and continents but
their album art had one thing in common
they were all sitting in the exact same
chair and it wasn't just them this chair
popped up on album covers everywhere now
you could easily chalk this up to being
one of many weird album cover trends
over the years but in the 1970s when
these album covers were pretty much
unavoidable they were actually following
a photography trope that was 100 years
in the making
[Music]
let's start with this photograph of
Charles Darwin the famed naturalist
relaxing in his old age at his English
home in 1880 on this wicker chair at the
turn of the century with her furniture
was all the rage its success was driven
by the fact that breezy open-air spaces
like verandas and porches were in high
demand this was long before homes were
air-conditioned and when the summer came
around no one in their right mind and
with a decent amount of money wanted to
overheat this June 1914 guide on how to
have a cool house suggest replacing
walls with curtains building sleeping
porches and filling the entire living
space with wicker furniture in short
brings summer into the house
[Music]
outside of the home liquor was used in
resort hotels at the beach and on ocean
liners and passenger planes and it
wasn't just furniture there were wicker
baby carriages and wheelchairs and this
thing but perhaps its most lasting
function well besides baskets was its
use in portrait photography wicker was
light and easy to move around and it was
breathable great for when hot lights
warmed the studio more importantly it
could be woven into countless eye
catching decorative forms many of these
designs particularly this ornate
asymmetrical one were actually called
photographers chairs or posing chairs
from the late 18-hundreds well into the
20th century
no portrait was complete without a
trusty wicker chair now these were
everyday people a young woman a mother
and child a handyman and shoe polisher
but just as often you'd see portraits of
powerful influential people photographed
in wicker chairs often in seemingly
candid positions Mark Twain William K
Vanderbilt countless presidents hanging
out on their porches the wicker chair it
seemed was the superficial equalizer
they dressed up your average citizen and
made powerful figures seem approachable
and the Styles changed along with the
trends while many were designed in the
US and Europe a few incredibly popular
models came from Asia those pieces were
recognizable by their hourglass shaped
bottom and if you open the magazine or
newspaper by 1920 one particular style
captured people's attention the peacock
chair
it's hourglass shape morphed into a
large throne like back and it was often
described as picturesque elegant and
majestic by the 1920s the peacock chair
took center stage and ads for summer
home furniture and when the burgeoning
film industry was producing its first
crop of movie stars it was a natural fit
for portrait photography but let's
backtrack for a second to one of the
earliest photographs of the chair I
could find it's not as a movie star it's
a portrait of a mother with her child
published around 1914 it's titled
jailbird in a peacock chair this woman
was a prisoner serving life for killing
her husband and it was likely taken at
bill Abbott prison and the Philippines
at the time the photo was taken the
Philippines were under US role and
American tourists were visiting the
islands by the boatloads beloved prison
was an unlikely attraction not only did
it serve as a jail it was also a
manufacturing facility equipped with its
own sales department for shoppers to
peruse this 1913 write-up from an
American tourist describes the place and
mentions the infamous chair it says we
are familiar with the queer shaped chair
made of rattan called some peacock chair
it's made at de lavit prison and a 1916
vogue article about shopping in the Far
East it says a stop at the prison is a
must this name was prisoner likely took
part in making those chairs she wasn't
famous or a powerful figure but sitting
in the chair transformed her into
something regal by the 1960's dozens of
iconic figures had posed with that same
chair poets writers presidents famed
actresses the chair appeared in
television and film like in my fair lady
which was set during the turn of the
20th century Cecil Beaton the set
designer for the film was obsessed with
wicker furniture this picture of Marilyn
Monroe he took it
around the same time album cover
designers picked up on the trend and
over the next two decades portraits of
artists in the peacock chair persisted
these covers can be broken up into a few
categories one I like to call the casual
leg
[Music]
there's the close-up and the group shot
[Music]
for this one the person is just randomly
in an open field and finally there's
this one best represented by Funkadelics
1979 album uncle jam wants you which
references to specific things the Uncle
Sam once you army recruitment poster and
this photo of Black Panther Party co
founder and leader Huey Newton sitting
in the peacock chair
[Music]
in 1967 when that photo was taken it
immediately became a visual
representation of the Black Power
movement and the chair took on a whole
new meaning it showed up at Black
Panther meetings and rallies even when
Newton couldn't it took up residence in
all its glory at the center of the stage
while most album covers with a peacock
chair tree their inspiration from the
casual glamour of mid-century celebrity
portraits some artists saw it as an
assertion of their cultural power even
today that's one of this chairs most
lasting legacies the peacock chair album
cover petered out in the 1980s and was
replaced by more minimalist and intimate
portraits of people but it remains one
of the most referenced chairs in
photography perhaps because it makes and
everyone sitting in it look really cool
[Music]